[Musique]
eacom normalement vous me répondriez i
comme icare en choeur mais à l'époque du
roi ordinateur à l'époque du e-commerce
du e-learning de l'e-mail à l'époque où
m i devant le mot le maquis d'un très
branché rimmel vous pourriez me dire i
comme un tas d'exemples du quotidien qui
redeviennent y pour se faire une vie aux
côtes demain alors il m'est venue l'idée
d'un loufoque et tolérant islam qui
j'espère vous arrachera un sourire
messieurs mesdames je buvais donc un thé
glacé dans mon hiver quand une alarme a
résonné de son timbre clair je ne
bougeais pas c'était mon immobile qui me
donnait des nouvelles d'une rencontre
des bills une fille stupide rencontré la
veille une icône avec qui j'avais
partagé une fondue bourguignonne
elle n'a jamais jamais été d'accord pour
venir voir un film d'horreur russe chez
moi de ligue or il faisait froid
j'avais l'impression d'être hiberner et
la fille étaient intellectuellement
illimitées elles étaient vieilles jeu
l'a trouvé immature et voilà l'immoral
de cette rencontre de cette futile
aventure c'est que je vais rester seuls
ces prochains jours devant mon
ordinateur je vais me concocter mon
programme perso mon fil conducteur
d'abord je vais résister à monsmier le i
dream elle qui tous les jours m'appelle
et me rappelle non j'ai plutôt de faire
un star wars devant un plat japonais un
ebook ou j'écrirais un m'amuse un poème
salle est d'une autre époque
une diode d'une autre époque ou alors je
vais jouer pour me changer les idées où
je rencontrais une dealeuse avec qui je
vivrai une idylle pour me ravitailler
je ferai de la peinture sur ma
messagerie quand je me mêle les pinceaux
ou gérer voir mon ami algérien ibrahim
le roi des réseaux sociaux un illettré
qui vit l'instant présent devant sa télé
l'immédiat et comme il est irresponsable
il me donnera son billard en bois bien
en bois j'ai pas de voiture pas de
véhicule faut que je cherche tout ça sur
mon emule et je peux pas prendre le
métro je vous le rappelle jusqu'à
lamielle station hydromel et puis je
voyagerai par tous
tous les continents un week end à rome
avant de traverser l'idaho évidemment et
puis j'irai dans la vie de la plus
branchée du jura la plus fun en effet il
faudra qu à l'idole des jeunes je
mettrai le feu avec mais imo l'aide
danseurs folichon jusque sur le site de
l'école d'administration et comme je
suis à paris
j'irai sur aussi de lire une escaut et
le rhinocéros
j'ai mis très pour terminer comme une
tranche de saucisson qui annonce le
printemps une hirondelle
je reviendrai dans nos contrées
méridionale sous mon nom brel déguster
mon pastis en mangeant un esquimau un
peu mou de déguster mont anis en faisant
igloo et cloud et puis fond je réduis en
train de vie que j'arrête de m'acheter
de trop tchermobile je viens de me faire
irradier par ma banque pour trop de
dépenses inutiles et tout ça devant une
vidéo passionnantes comme un album
d'astérix
c'est devenu mon idée fille mon id fix
me visionner toutes les conférences tedx
merci
[Applaudissements]